well I was part of a three-man award
it's a little hard because I think that
the descriptions they might give would
be different than mine so I have to
speak for all three of us and so I think
it has something to do it's hard for a
third well a 13 or 14 year old would
know about that was something called the
stock market or the housing market we
have done work on understanding what
drives these markets and you know what
why do they move through time and what
patterns can you expect them to show
looking at from my perspective I was
always among the three of us the one
that was most skeptical about
rationality of human behavior basically
these markets can go crazy sometimes
that was my view and it colored the kind
of work that I did I don't know that I
proved that markets go crazy but I think
the evidence that i showed inclines
readers in that direction